الى ملف الاحتجاجات الايرانيه الان حيث لا
بادره لاطفاء نار هذه الاحتجاجات سواء
بحمالات القمع والاعدام هكذا يرى معارض
السلطات الايرانيه على الاقل لكن بينما
تعتمد الحكومه الايرانيه هذه الطريقه في
التظاهرات التي عمت انحاء البلاد وخرجت عن
السيطره اضاف المحتاجون الى قائمه
شعاراتهم المناهضه للحكومه عباره تقول
انهم سيقاتلون حتى الموت وحتى يستعيد
ايران النظام الذي بدا بوصف المحتاجين
بمثل الشغب والمخربين احدث اوصافه ليقضي
عليهم بطريقه اخرى نعتاهم بالمفسدين في
الارض بل باعداء الله كذالك ثقه هذه
الاتهامات امام القضاء الذي اصدر ثلاثه
احكام اضافيه بالاعدام بحق من وصفهم
بمرتكبي الاعمال الاعمال الشغب في
الاحتجاجات التي اعقبت مقتل الفتاه
العشرينيه
يعيد التاريخ نفسه اذا في الذكرى السنويه
الثالثه الاحتجاجات عام 2019 والتي لم يقل
التعامل معها عن قمع اليوم فتقارير
المعارضه تقول ان الف شخص فقد حياتهم
بينمالا الاف اعتقلوا حينها لليوم الثاني
على التوالي يدخل المدنيون الى ساحات
الاسواق والى السوق الكبير او البازار في
طهران فيجدون ابواب المحل تجاريه مو صداقه
بسبب الاضرابات
توسع نطاق هذه الاضرابات اذا من العاصمه
طهران ليصل الى عشرات المدن من بينها مشهد
وصفهان وسندج وبندر عباس وكريم نجاح
[موسيقى]
اذا حمى الاحتجاجات وصلت الى كبرى الاسواق
ما الذي يعني ذلك اغلاق ابواب العمل في
بازارات معروفه يشفي بان الانتفاضه مستعصب
الاقتصاد الايراني فالاسواق الكبيره ما هي
الا سريان رئيسي يضخ الاموال للدوله اي
انها ايضا رمز للاستقرار المادي بالتالي
فان اصحاب هذه المتاجر ونعني رجال الاعمال
الكبار انضموا الى ركب الاحتجاج بطريقتهم
هم ايضا ما عدوا يثقون بالحكومه وانقلبوا
عليها لحسب احدث اصيله نشرتها منظمه
الحقوقيه قتل ما لا يقل عن 340 متظاهرا
خلال حمله القمع وتشمل الحصيله الصادره عن
هذه المنظمه القتلى في محافظه
سيستانلوستان المتخمه لباكستان والذين لا
يقلوا عددهم عن 100 و 123 شخصا
ووفقا لارقامها اعتقلت قوات الامن
الايرانيه ما لا يقل عن 15,000 شخص وهو
رقم تنفيه طهران
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]